recently there's his brother he told us
an incredible reminder story that
happened to him and it just moved me to
powder to tears and I thought I need to
share this with you guys
so basically what happened is that this
is brother he went to the Masjid on the
25th of December Christmas day to spend
some time just by himself written Quran
min - ah and I was in like a really good
place and he leaves a message in and as
soon as he steps outside he sees a poor
guy waiting for him and he gets annoyed
is like man this guy is like literally
waiting for me to harass me and the poor
guy came up to him asked him for some
money and his brother said you know what
I'm not gonna give you any money but
I'll buy some food fair enough however
every restaurant was actually closed
because it's Christmas day apart from
one he said which is so expensive he
doesn't even take his own family there
let alone feed somebody else there so he
looked at his wallet it was only 20
pound of c4 that's too much to give so
he took her 20 out and he gave it to the
brother this guy this poor guy they said
to look go in that restaurant and buy
yourself something small to eat and give
me the change so anyway what happened is
that now this poor girl goes inside the
restaurant he doesn't come back out
again and the brothers getting really
frustrated it's like first you took what
money now he's wasting my time is oh
because I went inside the restaurant
stormed in like fully intending to have
an argument and I see that poor guy
sitting on the table with a huge spread
of food in front of him all these dishes
and he's tucking in and I've got quite a
mad and I said to him look you told me
you're gonna meet me outside with my
money or the change at least and what
are you doing here
he just lifted up his hands and said
here's your 20 power and brother the guy
behind the counter is an owner and he
saw that I'm poor and he said whatever
you want take it for free so here's your
twenty pound back
now the brother got happy for oh well
I'll go for twenty pound bag it's like I
gave Southwark land got it back
straightaway he comes home to his wife
says look just like the foursome said so
the car doesn't decrease your I gave
this twenty this is what happened and I
got it back straightaway isn't that
amazing is why I've said not really
that's not how it went down
see what really happened is that Allah
gave you an opportunity gifts of the car
and you frown at that opportunity so
Allah took that opportunity and gave it
to the other person the owner of the
restaurant as for your 20 pound Allah
took it back and threw it back in your
face
so Allah now on the brothers saying that
he starts to tear up and he's like you
know what I'll learn a lesson that day
and the lesson was if ever Allah gives
you a chance to do any opportunity of
good even if it's small like this never
turn it down always do it willingly and
thankfully made a loss of pounds and
give us no fear